[Music]
the details of this terrible Calamity
the heaviest that had befallen the
Romans on foreign soil since the
disaster of crus in pathia I shall
Endeavor to set
forth varus quintius descended from a
famous rather than Highborn family was a
man of mild character and of a quiet
disposition somewhat slow in mind as he
was in body and more accustomed to the
Leisure of the camp than into actual
service in war that he was no despiser
of money is demonstrated by his
governorship in Syria he entered this
Rich Province a poor man and left this
poor Province a rich man when placed in
charge of the Army in Germania he
entertained the notion that the Germans
were a people who were men only in Limbs
and voice and that they who could not be
subdued By The Sword could be soothed by
the law with this purpose in mind he
entered the heart of Germania as the
though he were going among a people
enjoying the blessings of peace and
sitting on his tribunal he wasted the
time of a summer campaign in holding
court and observing the proper details
of legal procedure but the Germans who
with their great ferocity combine great
craft to an extent scarcely credible to
one who has had no experience with them
and are erase to lying born by
expressing their gratitude that Roman
Justice was settling these disputes
implied that their own barbarous nature
was being softened down by this new and
hitherto unknown method bringing
quintilius to such a complete degree of
negligence that he came to look upon
himself as City preator administering
Justice in the Forum and not a general
in command of an Army in the heart of
[Music]
Germania but dispatches from Germania
brought the baleful news of the death of
Varys and of the slaughter of three
three Legions of as many divisions of
Cavalry and of six cohorts an Army
unexcelled in bravery the first of Roman
armies in discipline in energy and in
experience in the field through the
negligence of its General the craft of
its enemy and the unkindness of Fortune
was
surrounded hemmed in by forests and
marshes it was exterminated almost to a
man by the very enemy whom it had always
slaughtered like cattle whose life or
death had depended so Sol upon the Wrath
or the pity of the
Romans the general varis had more
courage to die than to fight for
following the example of his father and
grandfather he ran himself through with
his sword of the two prefects of the
camp Lucius Aus furnished a President
Who after the greater part of the army
had perished proposed its surrender
preferring to die by torture at the
hands of the enemy than in battle Valor
ponus left tenant of varus who in the
rest of his life had been an inoffensive
and an honorable man also set a fearful
example in that he left the Infantry
unprotected by the Cavalry and in Flight
tried to reach the Rind with his
squadrons but Fortune Avenged his act
for he did not survive Those whom he had
abandoned but died in the act of
deserting them the body of Varys was
sent to Caesar but in spite of the
disaster it was honored by Burial in the
Tomb of his family from all this it is
evident that varus who was it must be
confessed a man of character and of Good
Intentions lost his life and his
magnificent Army more through lack of
judgment in the commander than a Valor
in his
soldiers piculus would have written his
account of the battle using a stylus on
wax or ink on Papyrus for more permanent
works though of course the original is
lost his words have been painstakingly
copied and carried down the Centuries by
medieval monks this video has been
sponsored by novium and their hover pens
are a fantastic classy gift idea and one
that reflects the importance of accuracy
and precision when recording the past
crowned one of time's best inventions of
2022 the novium hover pen Interstellar
Edition is a stylish and eye-catching
refillable ballpoint pen that hovers at
a 23.5° angle just like the Earth's
axial tilt created from aircraft grade
aluminium it also provides a comfortable
and smooth writing experience certainly
preferable to a stylus on wax the hover
pen is inspired by the heavens and the
premium version even comes with a real
Shard of meteorite embedded into it or
as the Greek said Diop PES things that
fall from Zeus they also have a new
future Edition which combines a roller
ball and fountain pen into one Sleek
package it's a great gift idea so click
on the link in the description and use
the code VP to get 10% off and free
shipping on any hover pen with Worldwide
[Music]
shipping in the year of the Lord's
Incarnation 1187 the king of Syria
Saladin gathered together an army as
numerous as the Sands of the seashore in
order to wage war on the land of Judah
Saladin ordered his forces to push on to
tiberias and besiege it on Thursday July
the 2 the city was surrounded by archers
and the battle was joined the Countess
and the galileans since the city was not
fortified sent Messengers to the count
and King with the news the Turks have
surrounded the city in the fighting they
have pierced the walls and are just now
entering against us send help at once or
we shall be taken and made
captives and so toward evening on
Thursday July the 2nd the king of
Jerusalem after he had heard the
galileon letter called together all the
leaders of the army so that they might
give counsel concerning the action to be
taken they all advised that at dawn they
should March out accompanied by the
Lord's cross ready to fight the enemy
with all the men armed and array in
battle
formation on Friday July the 3rd
therefore they marched out leaving
behind the necessities of life they came
to a hamlet called mariscala at this
place they were so constrained by enemy
attacks and by thirst that they wish to
go no further they were going to pass
through a confined rocky area in order
to reach the Sea of Galilee which was a
mile away for this reason the count sent
word to the king we must hurry and pass
through this area so that we and our men
may be safe near the water otherwise we
will be in danger of making camp at a
waterless spot the king replied we will
pass through at once the Turks were
meanwhile attacking the Army's rear so
that the Templars and the others in the
rear were barely able to struggle on but
suddenly the king ordered the tents to
be pitched thus we were betrayed to our
death the count when he looked back and
saw the tents pitched exclaimed alas
Lord God the battle is over we have been
betrayed unto death the kingdom is
finished and so in sorrow and anguish
they camped on a dry sight where during
the night there flowed more blood than
water the sons of Esau surrounded the
people of God and set fire to the desert
brush round about them throughout the
night the hungry and thirsty men were
harassed further by arrows and by the
fire's heat and
Flames at length after after the clouds
of death had opened light dawned on a
day of sorrow and tribulation of grief
and
destruction when day had dawned the king
of Syria forsook the city of tiberias
and with his whole Army came up to the
camping ground to give battle to the
Christians he now prepared to attack our
men our men formed their battle lines
and hurried to pass through this region
in the hope that when they had regained
a watering place and had refreshed
themselves they could attack and fight
the foe more vigorously but by this time
the sarens had already arrived the
Infantry clambered at full speed to the
very Summit of a high mountain leaving
the Army to its fate the king the bishop
and the others sent word begging them to
return to defend the Lord's cross the
heritage of the crucified they replied
we are not coming because we are dying
of thirst and we will not fight again
the command was given and again they
persisted in their refusal the Templars
and Hospers meanwhile were engaged in a
fierce rear guard action they could not
win however because enemies sprang up on
every side shooting arrows and wounding
Christians the units gathered around the
Holy Cross where they were confused and
intermixed here and there the men who
were with the count of Tripoli in the
first group saw that the king the
hospitals the Templars and everyone were
all jumbled together and mingled with
the Turks they cried out those who can
get through may go since the battle is
not going in our favor we've now lost
even the chance to flee meanwhile
thousands and thousands of syrians were
charging at the Christians shooting
arrows and killing them A large group of
pagans charged on the Infantry and
pitched them from the top of the Steep
Mountain to whose Summit they had
previously fled they destroyed the rest
taking some captive and killing others
upon seeing this the count and his men
who had been riding onward together with
Balan of Naples and Reginald of sidon
turned back the speed of their horses in
this confined space trampled down the
Christians and made a kind of bridge
giving the Riders a level path in this
manner they got out of that narrow place
by fleeing over their own men over the
Turks and over the cross
the sarens gathered around the Lord's
wooden cross the king and the rest and
destroyed the
church what more can be said the sarens
triumphed over the Christians and did
with them as they pleased what can I say
it would be more fitting to weep and
wail than to say anything alas should I
describe with impure lips how the
precious wood of the Lord Our Redeemer
was SE seized by the damnable hands of
the Damned woe to me that in the days of
my miserable life I should be forced to
see such
things I believe you will be astonished
at seeing this letter on account of the
slight certainty that could have existed
as to my being alive I've not had an
opportunity to write to you for more
than a year I've not done so until now
God has brought me to these states of
Flanders where I arrived 12 days ago
with the Spaniards who escaped from the
ships that were lost in Ireland Scotland
and Shetland which were more than 20 of
the largest in the Armada the gallion
San Pedro in which I sailed received
much injury from many heavy cannonballs
and although they were repaired as well
as was possible at the time there was
still some hidden shot holes through
which much water
entered after the fierce engagement we
had off Cali on the 8th of August
continuing from the morning till 7:00 in
the evening our Armada being in the act
of retiring the fleet of the enemy
followed behind to drive us from their
country but seeing that the enemy had
stopped some of the ships in our Armada
trimmed up and repaired their damages I
remained in the ship in which we were in
imminent danger of death because she
opened so much with a storm that sprang
up that she continuously filled with
water and we could not dry her out with
the pumps all the Armada proceeded
scattered in such manner by the storm
that some ships went to Germany others
drove on the islands of Holland and
Zealand into the enemy's hands others
went to Shetland others to Scotland
where they were lost and
burned more than 20 were lost in the
Kingdom of
Ireland as I said the ship I sailed in
was attached to two others very large to
afford US Aid if they could not being
able to weather round Cape clear in
Ireland on account of the severe storm
which arose upon the bow we were forced
to make for the land with these three
ships which as I say were of the largest
size and to Anchor more than half a
league from the shore where we remained
for 4 days without being able to make
any provision nor could it even be
made on the fifth day there sprang up so
great a storm on our Beam with a sea up
to the heavens so that the cables could
not hold nor the sails serve us and we
were driven ashore with all three ships
upon a beach covered with very fine sand
Shut in on one side and the other by
great rocks such a thing was never seen
for within the space of an hour all
three ships were broken in pieces so
that there did not Escape 300 men and
more than 1,000 were drowned among them
many persons of importance captains
gentlemen and other officials
Don Diego Enriquez died there one of the
saddest deaths that has ever been seen
in the world in consequence of fearing
the very heavy sea that was washing over
the highest part of the Rex he took his
ship's boat that was decked and he and
the son of the count of via franka and
two other Portuguese gentlemen with more
than 16,000 duckets in jewels and Crown
pieces placed themselves under the deck
of the said boat and gave the order to
close and cork the hatch Way by which
they had entered but thereupon more than
70 men who had remained alive jumped
from the ship to the boat and while she
was making for the land so great a wave
washed over her that she sank and all on
Deck was swept
away then she drifted along rolling over
in different directions with the waves
until she went ashore where she settled
wrongs side up and by these mischances
the gentleman who had placed themselves
under the deck died
within more than a day and a half after
she had grounded some Savages arrived
who turned her up for the purpose of
extracting nails or pieces of iron and
breaking through the deck they drew out
the Dead Men Don Diego Enriquez expired
in their hands and they stripped him and
took away the jewels and money which he
had and as it would not be right to
admit my own good fortun and how I got
on to land I say that I placed myself on
the top of the poop of my ship and
having commended myself to God and to
Our Lady and from then I gazed at the
terrible spectacle many were drowning
within the ships others casting
themselves into the water sank to the
bottom without returning to the surface
others on rafts and barrels and
gentlemen on pieces of Timber others
cried aloud in the ships calling upon
God captains through their chains and
Crown pieces into the sea the waves
swept others away washing them out of
the
ships most of her compliment of men and
all the captains and officers were
already drowned and dead when I
determined to seek means of safety for
my life and placed myself upon a piece
of the ship that had been broken off and
the Judge Advocate followed me loaded
with crown pieces which he carried
stitched up in his waist coat and
trousers I managed to find another
resource which was to take the cover of
a hatchway but when I tried to place
myself upon it it sank with me to a
depth six times my height below the
surface and I swallowed so much water
that I was nearly drowned when I came up
again I called to the Judge Advocate and
managed to get him upon the hatchway
cover with myself but in the act of
casting off from the ship there came a
huge wave breaking Over Us in such a
manner that the Judge Advocate was
unable to resist it and the wave bore
him away and drag around him crying out
and calling upon God while
drowning eventually there came four
waves one after the other and without
knowing how or knowing how to swim they
cast me upon the shore managing to rest
a little I began to doze and when fast
asleep at about 1:00 in the night I was
disturbed by a great noise of men on
Horseback there were more than 200
hundred of them who were going to
plunder and destroy the ships I turned
to call my companion to see if he slept
and found he was dead which occasioned
me great Affliction and grief there he
lay on the ground with more than 600
others without there being anyone to
bury them not even poor Don Diego
Enriquez
after we'd been citizens of Moscow for 4
weeks Napoleon refused the peace treaty
proposed to him and the Army which had
Advanced some 30 hours further on had to
retreat because the Russian army
stationed in mavia was approaching now
it was October the 17th and Napoleon
held an army review and announced the
departure of October 18th early in the
morning at 3:00 with the warning that
whoever should delay one hour would fall
into the hands of the enemies all beer
Brandy Etc was abandoned and whatever
was still intact was ordered to be
burned Napoleon himself had the Kremlin
undermined and blown
up all had an odd experience as they set
out for they filled as far as was
possible everything with sugar and
so-called Moscow tea in order to
withstand the future misery then
everyone packed up and the enemy
attacked us all ran in a crowded Retreat
the Army moving toward kuga with the
kexs in front of us and beside us those
who were too weak we to carry their
weapons or knapsacks threw them away and
all looked like a crowd of
[Music]
gypsies then we came to a second City
barov here the city was immediately
Ablaze and in order for us to get
through soldiers had to be used to
quench the Flames Camp was pitched by
this city and it became dark one no
sooner thought of resting then the
Russians fell Upon Our Army and cut off
many as captives everything was in
confusion and during almost the whole
night the throng had to retreat to mhis
everyone running so as not to fall into
the hands of the enemy because of these
considerable losses Cannon munition
wagons coaches and baggage wagons by the
hundreds had to be thrown into the water
and where that was not impossible all
wagons were burned not one wheel being
permitted to remain whole the fighting
the shrieking the firing of large and
small guns hunger and thirst and all
conceivable tor moments increased The
NeverEnding confusion indeed even the
lice seemed to seek Supremacy for their
number on both officers and privates was
in the
thousands in these days it snowed for
the first time and the snow remained the
cold arrived at the same time too and
the freezing of the people multiplied
the number of the Dead no one could walk
50 Paces without seeing men stretched
out half or completely
dead we arrived at smolens on November
the 12th having made from Moscow to that
City 26 days and nights of travel
without pausing a day if we traveled
only 12 hours daily then we had
retreated 312 hours up to smolin here we
settled down and had to camp for 2 days
as had been reported to us beforehand we
were to engage in batt battle with the
Enemy here and also get bread and flour
from the
warehouses neither of the two reports
however proved to be true the distress
mounted Higher and Higher and horses
were shot and eaten while we tarried two
days at smin the Russians Advanced and
awaited us at Minsk everyone hastily
flared Cannon was thrown into the water
the hospitals were nearly all left to
the enemy and as were commonly rumored
the hospitals were set a fire and burned
with their
inmates now as the March went on I had
to leave my sled behind and lay my
baggage on the horse upon which I also
mounted often during the day The cold
increased again that same day and the
road became as smooth as a mirror from
the rain so that the horses fell down in
great number and could not get up again
however since my horse was a native of
the country it had no horseshoes it
could always help itself up again when
it had fallen it had even the good
custom wherever we went downhill of
sitting down on its rump bracing its
front feet forward and sliding into the
valley in this fashion without my
dismounting at night in De brna when the
enemy had given up their Maneuvers
everyone settled down in and around the
place every night the fires for warming
could be seen over a region 4 hours long
and wide rening the sky like red cloth
again and again people died and
sometimes froze to death these were
people who pressed towards the fire but
were seldom permitted to get there so
they died away from the
fire every Soldier was like an officer
now since none of the uniforms showed
any distinction in rank and no Superior
could command a private officers were
beaten away from the fire just as
privates were whenever they tried to
press forward without merited claim only
Mutual support still procured true
friendship
I thought of my friends at home and
compared my misery and approaching end
with my former life of Plenty I
remembered a common saying at home a
campaign is always made out to be worse
than it was with this common notion I
consoled myself thinking it's well that
you my beloved kindreds and friends know
nothing of my condition for it would
only cause you pain and it would be of
no use to
me
when we came near the Barina River there
was a place where Napoleon ordered his
Park horses to be UNH harnessed and
where he ate he watched his army pass by
in the most wretched condition what he
may have felt in his heart is impossible
to surmise his outward appearance seemed
indifferent and unconcerned over the
wretchedness of his soldiers only
ambition and lost honor may have made
themselves felt in his heart and
although the French and allies shouted
into his ears many Oaths and curses
about his own guilty person he was still
able to listen to them
unmoved after his guard had already
disbanded and he was almost abandoned he
collected a voluntary core at D brna
which was enrolled with many promises
and received the name of holy Squadron
after a short time however this existed
in name only for the enemy reduced even
them to
[Music]
nothing
finally we came to alburg and for the
first time were given regular
quarters from this city I went onto
malava and at that place received
quarters again it was just Christmas Eve
a date I would not have known had I not
leared it from the landlord here I also
washed myself for the first time the
washing of my hands and face proceeded
very slowly because the crusts on my
hands ears and nose had grown like fur l
dark with cracks and cold black
scales my face resembled that of a
heavily bearded Russian peasant and when
I looked in the mirror I was astonished
myself at the strange
appearance I washed then for an hour
with hot water and soap however I felt I
had only become somewhat smoother and
lighter but I could not notice any
removal of the Blackness and the
scales
[Music]
the general said he wanted some Marines
to man the first troop ship that lands
isn't it Splendid we've got the job
Wedgewood illingworth Parker and myself
also we shall see the whole thing I
believe we start the landing this week I
think it will be short but sharp to take
galipo about midnight the anchor was
weighed and we we stood out to see sleep
was impossible such was the crowded
state of the ship not to mention the
intense excitement of our mission it was
a glorious
night now we were fairly embarked in our
perilous Enterprise and one thought with
a thrill that the Dawn would bring our
baptism of fire one felt somehow as if
one were grasping Hands Across the
centuries with the great adventurers of
ancient times was it on such a night as
this that the Roman Fleet put out from
the gala Shores towards the unknown
Cliffs of Britain did Norman William
gaze out at that same silvery moon when
his flotilla sat out on their great
Enterprise and the old Crusaders with
their warlike Spirits watching eagerly
the start of this new Crusade against
the ancient foe we felt that night on
the Old River Clyde that we were living
history over again as we forged ahead
towards the Turkish
Coast
about 2:00 we slowed down to a mere
crawl and we know we were near our goal
clearly now we could hear the guns
although as yet we could see nothing of
the ships the dull thudding Drew nearer
and nearer and the more distinct as we
slid slowly ahead until all on a sudden
away to starboard we saw a red flash
through the MC and the rolling boom that
followed told us we were nearing the
fleet and the the the great bombardment
had begun almost at once the CDE began
to speed up and soon we were forging
ahead towards the booming guns it was
now light enough to discern the black
shapes of Warships lying on both sides
of us underhead and soon we could only
dimly make out a darker gray line along
the horizon that showed the land nearer
and nearer we grew passing between lines
of great ships that flashed and smoked
and thundered and all of a sudden the
dawn rang along the Eastern Horizon in
streaks of scarlet and gold and we saw
that we were almost in the midst of the
fleet and there a way to Port was a line
of shore undulating in rows of round
topped Hills that were Spangled with
sudden flashes of scarlet flame it was
the Turkish coast and The Guns of the
fleet were preparing our way now we were
right in the midst of the battleships
and the Thunder of their guns seemed to
Rend the firmament all of us sudden
there were two plops in the water a few
yards short of the ship and we were now
fully conscious that shells were being
fired at the C from somewhere or other
and falling uncomfortably close too
there was a soft jar that quivered from
end to end of the ship and she was
ground all was now excitement on board
up till now not a shot had been fired
from the shore and indeed we had begun
to wonder whether the landing was to be
unopposed but hardly had the Hopper's
bow appeared Beyond her huge consort
when the whole whole slope leapt into a
roar of firing and a tempest of lead
poured down upon the devoted craft and
her Gallant
crew disaster overwhelmed her in an
instant nothing could live in such a
torrent of lead and in a moment the midi
at the wheel and every soldier on the
deck of the little ship was shot down
devoid of guidance the hopper went
astray and beached side on while the
barges all went out of line the
connecting ropes broke Under The Strain
and they came to rest in a hopeless
muddle with the farthest barge lying
helplessly in deep water about 20 yards
from the shore the bridge of boats had
failed and the officers hastily met to
construct a new plan out of the six
boats that formed one toe only one
reached the shore and beached side on
and out from among the crowded benches
only about a dozen men leapt into the
water and rushed for the sand the their
comrades still crouched upright in the
boats but they were strangely still shot
dead where they sat the other four boats
never reached the
shore as we watched in wordless horror
one of the boats floated slowly past us
bumping along our side and we could look
straight down into her motionless cargo
it was a floating
shambles slowly the Gastly boats scraped
along our sides and drifted out to sea
leaving us Frozen with a nameless horror
and an overpowering dread such was our
introduction to the glories of war and
when one big fellow turned his drawn
white face to us with a slow good God as
we stared at the vanishing boat we could
only look at him in a tight throated
silence and wonder what in Heaven's name
it all
meant then the order was given and up
they all leaped and rushed for The Rock
while a hail of rifle and machine gun
fire beat upon them wildly they leaped
from boat to boat in that Gallant Rush
while we on the ship cheered wildly at
the sight until they reached the last
boat when they leaped down into the
water and started waiting towards the
rocks that were their goal holding up
their rifles high above their heads but
to our horror we saw them suddenly begin
to flounder and fall in the water
disappearing from View and then
struggling to the surface again with
with uniform and packs streaming only to
go down again never to reappear as the
hailing bullets flicked the life out of
the struggling
men the price to be paid was too awful
and at slightly less than 2 hours after
the Clyde had run ashore operations were
suspended and it was decided to wait
till Nightfall before a further attempt
at Landing should be made the beach now
presented a terrible spec iCal such of
us that were not engaged working the
guns would Crouch with ready rifle
waiting to catch a snapshot from behind
the bulwick at the dim figures that
flitted from house to house as the
shells smashed and wrecked the
buildings and that was all we saw of the
[Music]
enemy
thanks for watching and thanks to the
novium hover pen for supporting history
content on
YouTube